everybody gather round pull yourself a
little bit of champagne in our cups
every yeah how's it goin I'm sticky wait
playing no yeah we're playing you
realize we lie we're not live we're
shooting in another way and icky seaside
seas that's it really agreed to want a
seaside I want to switch fellows for my
appearance I would like a couple away so
we're on vacation and these are my
sisters this is Gemma if you don't know
her Oh if we jump in YouTube you guys
should stop yeah and we've some video on
her channel this is Bri hates everything
that has to do with YouTube do you hate
it I'm just well you talk louder because
I just am over it I just did wearing
seaside things and I didn't agree to a
second one so we're not on this seaside
sit I'm home on seaside sipping Marzian
sassy secrets so I'm gonna answer some
questions are you ready Bri yep begins
at makeup serves a shawl yeah let's show
these cups
look at these click home little yeah
it's but is taking up the whole screen
you could be a table I feel like I've
been a rap music video what hi hi I'm
ready done question
actually I told her she can play her
phone just to okay along I didn't know
that was an acid working okay guys so
what is our favorite thing to do on
vacation let's go to the pool pull
breathe like seaside secrets no sending
time with my family
she also likes eating doughnuts yeah yes
brominated how many did you know um I
think Baba you maybe just being with
family that's a good answer
si si si set sip Carolina wants to know
was our day Oh God right now we're just
sitting here chatting seaside sip and
talking to a camera Bri what are you
doing over there I don't care
Ben rail wants to know if I'm excited
for destiny oh yes I actually have a ps4
yeah thank you - I need a straw we
should cut little straws in here
this is gonna be such a terrible video
and I'm dreading it
let's go on to the next question is it
great snap hold on I'm gonna be out of
the shop for a second no fun snapchat
again but this is alive it's live braise
is live on the internet right now alive
here over here the next question is who
is the grossest sister can you answer
yourself
I in this shot both equally disgusting
breathe clean Oh she like showers and
stuff look I'm trying to snap over there
he's good see you guys can I be honest
after Jenny's are clean looking at me on
snapchat I just seen I don't you dare
snap I am obsessive snapchat if you
could rename your sister not stupid
question not answering that
now what is our favorite story memory
that we all share together see this is a
pretty great the only thing I remember
from when we were younger is when you
guys made me play baby Jesus and you put
me in some type of box okay well what
did baby Jesus is in the manger knees in
a crib so Mike you put me in a box only
one that would fit okay it's fair quite
fair but I think I probably remember a
few of them what did you want us to go
out and like purchase them yeah I hope
over manger I mean it and I think my
battery's gonna die enjoy all the
memories which we forget so I don't know
seaside seaside seven secrets that's the
one that said did you have any doughnuts
under this day but I think this I see
that's hip and cigarette did we get to
the question shut your mouth immediately
just getting up I love your mouth okay
hold up who was the most competitive Oh
Brianne she's a skittle her thyroid you
a skittle in your thyroid no no no sorry
problem but they think that never mind I
know I'm just kidding no no they said
they think what's wrong with me is like
I'm under methylated so it has to
contribute to all my black dress sticks
and very competitive have to be the best
of everything like a lot of things that
we can't cut yeah cut with okay that's
don't touch me
Breanna is the most competitive because
she will do handstands until she does
them perfectly like I'm like no I just
do the best that we put him in all brie
has to do alone win win win no matter
matter what Aubrey does is win we win no
matter what
she got winning on her - oh why didn't
we get bigger cups yeah because these
little cups add up
oh wait so we were talking about in
Jenna's book cuz I wanted to talk about
this I was a huge dean koontz fan cheers
but you don't find where I want war but
okay I don't you
Jenna started reading inaudible what was
your audible book aren't cars so I
totally forgot about the impudence Dean
I'm really sorry I know you're really
upset about this but I used to be a huge
dean koontz Han are you upset about it -
she's upset because she has germs in her
cup so for my audible book this month
I'm going to download a Dean Koontz book
I don't know which one I don't want to
download the moment year but then we can
talk about it hurry up okay fine you
have five hours I'm five hours in so you
could really yeah shoot I had to catch
up so anyway if you guys want to get
free audible for this month check out
audible.com slash iJustine you'll get a
free book freak there need a trial and I
recommend it Dean Koontz bakery get it
free Bree please do you like touch me
we're sorry yeah well I greet anymore
video drink okay no these are adding up
they might be a little I've gotta be
able to say and Brienne may physically
hurt me if we don't stop this video so
let me know look you guys get the link
is below if you'd like to get used my
habla code iJustine and check out
Jenna's video which we made before that
it's better popping of the champagne pop
my champagne it's a great video Brianne
was a little bit more than food and then
just seems a quiet button yeah she's how
it works here alright guys thanks for
watching I love you guys and we're all
of age so we are allowed to 24 and I'm
Thomas you guys use me my fans for you
because it's your beautiful I'm used
freedom actually used abused and
unappreciated
I do why leave me alone no come on my
shoes on the whole time let me down do
anymore symptom break it let's but
thanks Bri thanks Ronnie had it up here
oh my gosh get out have a mock up take
your break
well I can't help us look like I mean
try I did too
you can say it I think I look pretty
can he was disgusting put her necks over
her face